[Musique]
voir les enfants bosse moi vite vite pas
trop je descends j'ai une surprise
devinez pour qui pour pas prenez les
nicolas au
nom pour le petit chien perdu que je
leur ai apporté heures et hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
en appétit kia fait tiguan bonsoir tous
mes enfants
tu sais il est merveilleux ces petits
chiens il est presque aussi gourmand que
nous at il été sage
[Musique]
alors j'ai une surprise pour lui
voilà un gros collier
avec salaire ce quinté gatti c'est
exactement ce qu'il faut pour l
électrode mais c'est moi qui tiendrait
la laisse non c'est moi comme monsieur h
te dit tu sais pas t'occuper
il préfère se promener avec un homme
neuf panneaux non d'une a doucement
doucement moi je l'emmène ce toutou si
vous vous disputez vous tiendrez la
laisse chacun à votre tour
et tu t'es merci
[Musique]
il touche à tout le côté chic avec cet
allié petit
[Musique]
chouchou du bois choix bah c'est pas
sympa c'est vrai
voyons comment ta [ __ ]
médard
dans ce sport
non tu crois pas
moi
qui
donne de ce
téléphone on va répondre
[Musique]
alors c'est qui vous demandez à moi à
moi à l'eau nounours à la parole
bonjour monsieur
j'ai lu votre annonce
j'ai perdu mon chien émile émules
comment est il c'est un gros chien tout
noir je regrette monsieur celui que j'ai
trouvée est tout petit au revoir
monsieur
il a émis
[Musique]
vous voulez passer où il est plus là
mais tu petit chien chien alors petits
drôles il est l'heure de faire d'eau
douce
j'ai vite voire à nous quand qu'il ait
jamais connu petit chat perdu
[Musique]
madrilena ce bonne nuit le peut-il
bonne nuit tout où
on la retrouvera sa maman
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors nounours comment se porte notre
nouvel ami à merveille patron et se
tuait l'union est bien en route bonnut
des enfants embrasser bien fort vos
parents est fait
[Musique]
oh